how's it going friends subscribers cool
people who like here in this dork talks
what update you on a project that will
projects not really the word project
sounds like this one thing I did one
time check it out it's a science project
with the volcano and baking soda and
vinegar it's not that it's actually a
new weekly show that I have and since
you can see the title of this video it
is called awesome tacular and it is on
the Verizon go 90 Network what awesome
tacular is is I host it and talk about
all the newest that week in movies TV
shows comic book movies slash comic book
stuff Pam Horton lovely co-host and I we
sit down and we play video game but it
really is like a celebration of all
these different things that are fun in
the world of entertainment crush down to
about a 22 minute package for you if you
ever wanted to see me play video games
it's fun and I make dumb video game face
okay this is a concentrating entire time
like there's also some sketch comedy and
there's some the comedy ish segments
that don't actually have to do with
movie news just fun things to do I used
to do that on my channel back in the day
you know people wanted to see it back so
hey you can see it back there and since
the day that put this together they've
made a sizzle reel sizzle reel is just a
fancy word for a trailer I will play the
trailer for you now it's about 45
seconds or so enjoy get hyped have fun
here it is the fate of the Furious 8
there are cars vs. submarines with the
lovely Pam Horton we're gonna play again
that's just what I do while I play games
how excited all of us were when the
Phantom Menace was coming out up until
about nine years ago I was on my own
successful your friendly neighborhood
spider-man people love me
but those before there's a Wolverine
story group led by Steve Perry he is
killing it for the journey are they
gonna be good are they gonna be bad we
don't know but talking about it is
awesome calculus
so there is basically what you can
expect from the show awesome tacular
like I said it is hosted by me it is on
the Verizon Co 90 Network you can
download the app or go to the website
good news it's free it's no paywall you
don't have to pay a monthly subscription
don't put on your credit card
information you just watch it watch
enjoy and this is the thing I just want
to be completely honest with you guys
about it is only available in the United
States I know I feel like I want to say
don't kill the messenger but the
messenger is the host of the show that
is a Verizon thing that is their network
I hope eventually it spreads to other
realms of the world because the world is
a very big place I know I have a lot of
fans outside the United States just the
fact is that's their network that's the
way it is but like I said hopefully it
expands I do think they have a couple
episodes on there go 9 to YouTube
channel if you want to check that out
but new episodes every Friday so it's a
weekly show so if you don't get enough
of my face there you go there's more of
my favorites gonna squash the fears
right now no nothing on my channel is
changing nothing on my channel ever
changes I always want to reiterate that
too because I know there's like a big
stranger danger thing on YouTube it's
like you're doing other [ __ ] what's
gonna happen to your channel nothing is
it's always it will be here unchanged
unaltered just the way you like it but
in the world we're sticking to my core
channel it's fun to branch out and do
other things this is one of the other
things so again I put the link below
where you can check it out or you can
download the gun ID app so if you want
to support me and my new projects and my
new adventures in life up to see you
there I love you all and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to say
more
[Music]